[Music]
what up friends so a few weeks ago I got
a set of zip POI from juggling calling
these are the brand new sets of poi that
have hollow heads and tethers that go
all the way through them and that you
can slide back and forth
I also have been kind of uh cooped up
inside my apartment for several weeks
now while it has been very very cold and
frequently very rainy outside so it was
the first chance I've really had to come
play with them outside and I wanted to
share it with you Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flowers to benefit
your body and brain and today I'm giving
you a first look at me playing around
with these zip POI and giving you some
of my initial thoughts ahead of my
review before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel lay machinsky and Becca
pekunen thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so zip POI are kind of a new Twist on
contact POI I believe bow juggler came
up with the idea for these uh basically
what happens here is we have a normal
contact POI heads but they're drilled
all the way through and the tether has
handles on either end so you can slide
the head back and forth Bo's been coming
up with some pretty nifty videos showing
off different things that he can do with
these I have not played with them a
whole lot just yet but I want to change
that especially because I have to review
these POI in the coming months
so let's see what I come up with shall
we so just initial thoughts as I am
walking around trying to find a good
spot to flow these are quite a bit
heavier than a normal set of contact boy
I think that's because
um of course you know they they have the
handles on both ends and so those
handles add a little bit of weight plus
which they have what I think are HPC
tethers on them so these are pretty
beefy they're intended to work as like
as as static rope but a lot of the spots
where I usually like to set up are
either in the shade right now or there's
like a truck parked in them just kind of
obnoxious but uh I think for our
purposes today this spot will probably
do all right so I think I'm just going
to start off by doing some stuff that's
pretty familiar and that I'm used to so
I'll go ahead and just do some standard
POI spinning and maybe some contact
pointing some Gunslingers too
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so some initial thoughts
um so they definitely work for a lot of
more traditional uh POI spinning
um I don't notice a big difference with
them when I'm doing things like flowers
they actually seem to be a pretty good
fit for Gunslingers but uh static rope
just in general I think has that quality
I will say that I can feel the balls
jiggling around a bit as I'm doing a lot
of those tricks it's it's definitely
noticeable
um
I don't know that I would consider it a
good thing or a bad thing it just kind
of is I'm not like worried that the ball
is going to go flying anywhere but it is
something that is is you definitely have
an awareness of when you're spending
them
um I would definitely say that contact
POI is a little bit of an adventure with
these ironically enough
um most basic contact roles seem to
require just a little bit of tweaking
the one thing that I did find was really
challenging was doing folding lines
which just straight up become an
absolute adventure with these and you
have to make a lot of adjustments in
order to make them work which is funny
because they are made from you know the
same materials that a traditional set of
contact boy would be who knows the one
thing that I am going to say these don't
feel that great on is just my dance
style
because they're a lot heavier than I'm
used to and because these tethers are
pretty bulky I find that they don't
handle as quickly or as easily as I
would like for a lot of my POI dance
work
they just have a lot more weight and
inertia than I would like for a lot of
that so yeah that's uh that's maybe one
thing working against them at this point
but I think next up I'm going to try
playing around with actually sliding
these heads and seeing what I can come
up with that I like with them
[Music]
foreign
so the other camera's batteries ran out
and now I got to do this on my phone
which is super not great because it's
windy out today and the audio is not
going to be good at all but hey uh The
Show Must Go On Right
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
go through and learn some of the stuff
that I have seen uh both bojuggler as
well as uh voita stillbanko doing some
of their videos so let's see how that
goes
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
so my thoughts now
um I definitely appreciate the challenge
that is inherent in a lot of the more
manipulation style uh ZIP POI stuff
um kind of doesn't sit right with me
that so much of it requires like
stopping for a second and like putting
everything back in balance it kind of
just feels like you're leaving the
audience hanging there a little bit but
I do see the skill that's required to do
all that stuff there's definitely some
interesting stuff that this opens up for
sure
um so my full thoughts of course are
going to be coming in a review that is
going to drop in a couple weeks so let
me know your questions what do you want
to know about zip POI how they feel uh
the weights uh what works what doesn't
leave me a comment and let me know and
hey do any of you all out there already
own a set of zip POI what has your
experience been leave me a comment and
thank you so much to juggling calling
for sending me these POI to check out
and review if you got anything out of
this video please make sure to like
share comment and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel grow
foreign
this video would not be possible or not
for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you so very much one and all for
your very generous support if you out
there watching uh would like to support
the channel there's a bunch of ways to
do it number one you can go sign up to
my patreon you can do that over at
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi get access to a whole
bunch of rewards totally awesome you can
also go sign up for one of my online
courses over at learn.drexfactor.com I
have beginner intermediate and several
Advanced series on there so go check
those out
and finally I offer live stream classes
as well over at crowdcast.io
drexfactor and I focus on dance as it
pertains to POI spinning so go check
that out please and thank you cool so if
you want to check out some of my POI
equipment reviews I will leave a link to
a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look as well thanks so much for watching
make sure to get up and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace